the computer and Bishop E6 split
computer hits it directly
why is it so bad how bad can this be
computer is going crazy yeah computer is
going crazy for which exact reason yeah
that's the big question sure if this is
this is the way to go but this is always
in the air we know this old customer of
carpool games and so on once you played
H6 the structure is never very safe but
it feels like there should be something
something more violent than this uh hang
on but then can you start with Bishop B1
start with this yeah and then Stratton
Queen D3 because in the other structure
after 96 Fe you have always look F6 kind
of covering and then King F7 but now
with the opponent F7 it might be a
problem
it is a problem I mean how do we write
G6
what do you do yeah this is it this is
it I mean just a very simple Bishop B1
and we see that tabatavi for the very
first time in this game thinks and at
the right moment because he knows
exactly that public computer was saying
that black had to play something very
specific and it wasn't Bishop E6
yes the usual you're happy that you know
your opponent made a bad move but